what's about to happen in Bitcoin world
that's got everyone so intrigued and
that possibly could be contributing to
this recent surge so the level of
issuance of Bitcoin was determined by
the software in 2009 to be at a
decreasing rate over the subsequent
hundred or so years and and so if you
think about today 3600 Bitcoin are
issued every day as of next month it'll
be more like 1800 a day so the fact that
there's going to be less issuance every
day also means less supply is gonna hit
the market every day
and that'll possibly have a positive
effect on the price of Bitcoin so people
have known about this schedule forever
so how much of the recent surge I mean
it's really taken off in the last few
weeks would you attribute to this and
how much is other stuff and what might
that other stuff be I actually think
this is a relatively small part because
if you think about the impact on supply
it's less than 10% of the daily supply
of Bitcoin comes from the actual
issuance and so the other factors like a
capital flight from China speculation in
China people seeing Bitcoin as an
alternative to gold is a stable safe
haven asset I'd say those are impacting
the price of Bitcoin even more but this
is helping with this current cycle of
hype yeah let's do it look we have this
chart on here I don't know whether it's
specious or meaningful it shows Bitcoin
surging at the same time Chinese
currency is weakening how much activity
is coming out of China right now how
much is China which really sort of
driving the show here a lot of it a lot
of the Bitcoin transactions are
processed by in China on Chinese
transaction processors a lot of the
activity happens in Chinese exchanges
I'd even say a majority of transactions
happen there I'd say most of the
economic activity happens outside of
China but most of the processing and
speculation happens in China so there is
a connection there and it impacts the
short-term prices of Bitcoin quite a bit
now you said speculation so is that a
distinction between say using Bitcoin as
a way of getting around capital controls
yeah both both of them I think are very
important factors in China the more peep
want to get capital out bitcoin is a
convenient way to do it you buy bitcoin
in China you can take it out in any
other country and put it in a bank
account there and either circumvent or
just fly under the radar in terms of
Chinese regulations so that's a factor